what has happened to their citizens of
the reject Nation it is time for one
piece 10 ultimate episode Aaron how are
you I am incredible my body is ready I
am so ready to so is my head oh that's a
buggy reference ladies and gentlemen you
know what to do please go ahead and
leave a like on that video thank you so
much to all have been subscribed and
clicking the notification Bell because
we got one more episode to get to and
today I wanted to give a shout out to
the real rejects new merch shop reject
nationshop.com why isn't Greg wearing
one of those shirts because like the
professional planner is you forgot to
run the dryer so he's wearing this
sweater right now instead but look at
these designs that we have people are
always asking what are some of the best
ways to support the channel one of the
best ways to support the channel is to
get any one of these random shirts and
there's gonna be more coming throughout
the year and I got my sister on board to
become the head designer it's gonna be
like a family operation ladies and
gentlemen thank you guys so much you've
already bought yourself some teas you
better get one soon Buddy and lastly
full interesting over there a copy of
One Piece
patreon page let's get to it
[Music]
I know Luffy made a deal with you to
find our long clown but if this is
another one of your tricks what are you
gonna do bleed on me
because I said bleed on me
how do we know you're not leading us to
a trap I don't know about your hits
right come on I can sing a nice sea
shanty to pass the time oh
the neck is moving I bet that's an
Easter egg I just want to know if nami's
okay
a beautiful talented woman does not
choose to allow herself with a pirate
like our long Army clearly needs to be
rescued that's right you saved that
woman men
ah I like it I like the new one
those oranges they are
oh my God
oranges origin orange oranges Origins
actually it does not shut up everyone
shut up let's watch the show you're
ruining it for everyone
I saw the vision yeah yeah you saw what
I was going for
a bunch of hippies blowing bubbles in
your orchard it's not an orchard if it's
oranges right I don't know okay your
orange farm
NAMI it's your turn
Nami
Nami is that nami's mommy Nami you're a
vet
oh she had such a beautiful life before
all this Darkness
oh the fish hop
All In
strike
10 high I don't know what that means
[Laughter]
Queen's full no so it's just regular
poker okay I still don't know what it
means
Richie we don't lie about money on this
crew I'll be back for the rest of your
Berry later
is that the implication it's what she
does
she's a thief
way to sync that up nice
[Music]
that's interesting because you're so
serious in Stern but this is the dream
that Luffy keeps talking to her about
yeah where did you get the book Nami I
took it from the bookstore
what it's not like I hurt anybody you
hurt the people you stole from I hate
eating tangerines every day I hate being
poor you have Bubbles and oranges no
chica's not my
damn
or
she had it coming
I know it's 20 23 but this was 20 years
ago it would just be like hit that kid
I kept a plate on the stove for you
I'm not hungry classic parent move beat
your ass and come with kindness I got
dinner ready if you stop all that crying
the day I found
my unit has
oh [__] raised by a fighter nice
when I saw you
I knew I had to live
I had to live so I could take care of
you she found purpose hey there's some
great parents in this show I love the
heart this show has I have another job
for you in the meantime one of the
villages is late with their true
retainment which one
Cocoa Village
no his job
requires a human touch
oh arlong knows exactly what he's doing
I always wondered what happened to the
infamous red legs have captain of the
cook Pirates yeah when I was dies a fall
ball in me and the only thing under my
command is this restaurant are they
gonna kill him off right now I hope not
a young pirate who was here recently
name of Luffy he's unlucky if I remember
my regulars oh you'll remember this one
straw hat stretchy did you choose Straw
Hat goofy base his name off of Luffy
no he couldn't have
[Music]
they do a really great job at knowing
how to gray out a lot of their
environment but keep our Central
characters still colored and saturated
in their outfits oh yeah it's impressive
how they do that with their designs
our long did this please
please
is that the same girl I think so yeah
black girl blue hair yeah not a lot of
those in this world hey
they're all the same Aaron don't be
racist
it's like she looks like her
Nami Nami Nami at the orange Orchard if
that's what it's called
I found NAMI so fast yeah that was
really quick
[Laughter]
Oh Sister beef also I haven't said it
all but Nami is cute as hell dude she's
like
it was fine as [__] and you promised to
never steal again is that will force
yeah is that I think it is what the hell
what the Cameo like the only name actor
in this thing so far what's going on
oh this is why she hates Pirates
oh my God shoot a duck she was abducted
oh or she chose to go with them oh I'm
gonna make a guess she is playing the
long game she actually wants to kill
arlong and his people over because it's
like RR yeah
[Applause]
so he's strong
[Music]
no no already damn he just got here no
no he's right here okay
no I don't need any
part of your
system away they love you take the rest
of these clowns and sail away from here
I never want to see you again
you don't mean that
cry a little bit a little bit give me a
tear back to the boat before the
fishermen find us sail the hell out of
here nah Luffy's persistent I think she
was very clear she wants us to leave you
don't know women they never say what
they mean
the villagers are terrified of her not
all of them I'm a pirate Hunter
we're here to collect our lungs Bounty
smart man yeah
turn around and leave now that's what
I've been saying hey
let's start with nami seems you know her
very well she's a thief with no
conscience
and when there's no more lift to take
she leaves and doesn't turn back you
really think it's a long game
I feel like she just went down the wrong
path she doesn't like him and she like
he screwed over her town so she's gonna
be playing the long game you're not
special and I can't help you how about a
meal
what
[Laughter]
Sanji with the charm
huh oh no no no pretty good oh yeah I
have a feeling daddy Pirate's gonna die
already you think so
I have to reunite in episode 487. I took
my choice
there's a new generation and they're
coming up Buns of impulsive children are
ready to be enjoyed
you leave it too long it will go bad
a lot of deeper context to this
conversation
just serve whiskey
okay maybe he's a
I don't know because you brought out the
wine he's gonna die I thought it was
excited for a special occasion like it's
time to meet his I feel like he's going
I don't know his last drink getting
death Vibes yeah
love the Prosthetics on the fish men
yeah great job HP Lovecraft
uh
uh what
[Music]
it's like a subdivision of the Marines
this [__] has whiskers yeah
I have additional concerns how many
about twice as many as that let's double
our usual Arrangement that is where
twice as many means yes
[Laughter]
you know this is the best thing I've
eaten my entire life
better than a tangerine
you really need to know about Nami the
truth is
what's going on is it like a Thanos and
Gamora situation is that what you're
getting at I can see that yeah that
makes some sense
well you think she's nebula who's the
blue hair yeah in a way Jimmy does a
hundred thousand very
adult you got the bucket hat in the
chain that's hilarious take it
that's all I got
[Music]
three plates on the table ah damn it I
have two daughters you'll have to pay
for the 50 000 Berry each he gave you
everything I had too bad for you it
ain't enough no that is [__] up
oh it's a family reunion
because you are my daughters and I would
never deny that
wow she probably hates her because she
she said something
no no no no no no
oh man I love you girls
foreign
I think you're right
[Laughter]
oh man wait nami's working for the
pirate that killed your mother oh God
gorgeous shot I was just thinking the
same thing best Dynamic on the show
these two she made her choice
I ended up hearing about Nami from other
people she told you to leave Luffy so
did you hmm
how do you know she's not one of our
Long's crew
same way I knew you weren't going to
kill me when I cut you down from that
cross
same way I knew about usop Luffy can see
people for their potential and who they
can really be I know Nami is good
to know it too
yeah I don't think exactly a long con I
think she feels like included a lot of
guilt oh yeah my mom's dead because of
me this is like her punishment she's
serving her pendants I hope it's a long
cone she's got to get revenge for her
mama it's not too easy keeping Marine
patrols out of the area
and with your increase in activity I
guess it's just the price of doing
business you're not smarter than people
give you credit for
you shouldn't have said that man
shouldn't have said that don't
discriminate does it surprise you that I
have intelligence
enslave my people slavery has been
abolished what's your Prejudice for me
who have all the same rights as humans
silly
[Laughter]
anything intentionally cast a black guy
no
I can accept the terms of our usual deal
give it all back
you're smarter than people who gives you
credit for kill them kill them anyway
and what about our deal what about it I
have the money a hundred million Berry I
thought that money fair and square now
are you ready to honor our agreement wow
that's a lot of berry U.S dollar
translation that's like
200 dollars
[Laughter]
that's why our USA is number one baby
maybe there's a way for the rat to earn
some extra Berry after all what are you
doing
buying you a drink you can't we're on
Judy oh
come on God why don't you just shave his
hair it is so awful just commit man just
shave it off your head looks like a
penis
aren't you full of surprises
dude you're gonna confess maybe the
straw hat Pirates aren't the villains
that the Marines are making them out to
be you know something
's Luffy's grandfather
would you why would you why would you
say that
tell anyone he's gonna tell everyone
they say what you want about Lucy but
it's the real deal it doesn't matter not
to a man like Garb you color Outside the
Lines you get your arm chopped off
it's a little extreme if you ask me must
have been hard going off with the dad
like accent Morgan I am nothing
like that straw hat filler with a straw
hat came through here the other day they
have to change your heart
[Laughter]
[Music]
come on peace head last thing I want to
do is put myself in the middle of a
family dispute it's special reminds me
of another pirate we knew back in our
Glory Days you're not saying it's going
to make it less true
um the kid reminds me of gold Roger is
that the guy who had the the one piece
yeah is he related Luffy I still only
bought a coat sir
thank you for the meal you see he's not
gonna kill him have the Navigator said a
course immediately
for the Konomi Islands you have to know
when it's time to let him go
change is coming whether you want it or
not it's their turn now
just turn around
okay he's safe told you it would have
been satisfying if he died right here
maybe Luffy's the son of him
and then he that's nothing he's not
really the grandson of our villain oh
you think he just like took him
all took him in after yeah maybe he just
took him as a baby or something that
could be interesting Theory okay could
be an interesting Theory it isn't
interesting here
[Laughter]
now grave too
oh oh no no no no no there's important
stuff in there it's not what you think
you have no
oh and you're hiding it next to her
mother's body mommy what kind of monster
her for her mother's
mother's death unless some other thing
happens in this flashback which we're
about to find out I need to speak with
you and who are you my name is Nami
prepare to die you wanna kill me little
girl
no
I want to join your crew
say what
whoops I have something you want because
she's got a black guy fetish
[Music]
I killed your mother
to come work for me how can you trust a
human like that why would you do that
because you have something I want told
arlong I'd work for him on one condition
that he let me buy back Cocoa Village
that would take a lifetime I have the
money and now I can buy the freedom of
the village and everyone in it why'd you
have to have everyone hate you she can
let the secret get out well I couldn't
lose you too
or anyone else oh that's really sad yeah
so you kept that secret oh the easiest
and you let me hate you
I'd want the crowd
[Laughter]
I want people to know how good of a
person I am
I've heard the Pirates are stashing
their plunder in this area you two
wouldn't know anything about that would
you
oh Luffy Zorro Sanji and I guess who's
up get some ass I guess it's mine 100
million Berry how did you know
how long put you up to this didn't he
watch yourself or we'll take you into
custody as well
oh
somebody do something oh I hate this I
hate this so much you Draconian [__]
damn it's so messed up dude I'm really
invested in everyone's personal motives
yeah yes let me go they can't do this
Let Me Wait get back that money ask your
friends for help if they were so close
to she was already at the 100 million
marks you should have clued in the straw
hat team
she's already used to keeping things so
close to the chest she doesn't trust
people anymore I'm just saying you know
I mean I agree with you the girl can't
trust now the time has come to restore
the natural order of this world
oh this is so sad yeah
man
all right just rage will burn through
Cocoa Village we will teach each and
every human their rightful place beneath
us you tell them fish needo
ask your friends for help ask your
friends for help
sad
I'm tattooed on your body dude
oh
I was gonna help you
I love this show man
[Music]
so good
I told you to get the hell out of here
you did you don't know anything about
what's going on here I don't
oh
[Music]
of course I will damn what a great scene
oh hell yeah oh man
God I love this
God I love this show
[Music]
that's right
damn look at this is a [__] live
action anime
oh man
what's that
they're attacking the village
uh-oh
[Music]
no
ah
of course of course that's where it ends
can't wait for all five of them to be on
the same screen together all right all
right I got one more episode to go
through so just talk about the super
quick Aaron take it away oh man this
episode's incredible this episode was
incredible from the the themes of of
family you know the themes of protection
going on
um yeah man this episode was great from
start to finish like getting to see
nami's backstory finally after not
really knowing what her deal was the
entire time to realizing how
um full of heart and full of uh
selflessness she was
under the guise of being selfish and
pushing the people that she loves away
whether it be her sister whether it be
the straw hat crew and yeah seeing the
the lengths people will go to for family
I thought that was was really inspiring
and and really really meant a lot uh
yeah I just think that
this movie wasn't this episode wasn't uh
high in action as we've come to
to see over the course of the show but
just seeing that has the heart has the
um
I don't understand the emotionality of
it that scene we just watched was
incredible like Nami going into like
trying to find her um
I don't know well she lost everything
but yeah then her finally accepting
their help and then just seeing how
Luffy was able to be there for her and
believe in her like the fact that Luffy
is someone who just believes in people
to such a degree sees people and sees
things in people that they don't see in
themselves is incredible and I think
this is the first episode of the show
we've seen Luffy not have this
overwhelming like
um not not necessarily optimism but like
this gung-ho attitude he's very much
like kind of somber very serious for
most of this episode and I think for a
character who is very much like upbeat
for all the time I think it's important
to have those notes have those accents
for the character to really make them
feel more human because I think you
could easily with an adaptation run the
risk of a character feeling like a
cartoon but rather This Crew and Luffy
and themselves feels very dynamic as a
leader as a character
and yeah and just watching these
different people come together has just
been very satisfying of a journey and
yeah really this episode really got me
emotional
uh towards the end you know seeing what
nami's gone through seeing
like love through the face of of
rejection via fear and yeah just I loved
it man like didn't it didn't need the
action for me you know it had the
character and then also with uh with
sanji's like surrogate father and him
like in the role that he was playing in
here just all of it really came together
and nami's Mom you know like her
standing up for uh for her chosen family
just all of it really
really was impactful and yeah yeah it's
penultimate episode
and uh yeah I would be if this is a week
to week show like Aaron I'd be so
frustrated that it just ended right now
because I'm so excited to see them all
finally come together and accept each
other as a unit
yeah this was uh this is great yeah man
what'd you think yeah I think you're
you're right about that I think
thematically they were showing the uh
The Duality between like the types of
surrogate parents and types of parenting
that we have one side is like very
misguided kind of parenting or straight
up villainous parenting with our long
the evil captain guy
um even you call him penis head even
with even with his dad
that parenting side and then of course
you got
um
uh oh my God sorry it's been a day Nema
I'm already I've just like flaking on
everyone's name at the moment I've just
lost the whole episode about her
oh the uh nami's bomb Navi God damn it
yeah as I can see the letters I was like
what the hell is wrong with my brain
right now
um Nami and her her parents and and then
of course Sanji as well and looking at
like Again The Duality between those
types of parenting and how that affected
them too I thought was beautifully
thematically displayed here in this
episode and I think we've been watching
how these children have grown up into
adults and how that's affected them
you're even sort of watching over the
course of Luffy from where he was to how
he is in this episode you're watching
him go from being a boy into a man and
then it still manages to give you that
reward and cathartic line that you could
only pull off like lines like what when
he's when he like puts his hands up in
the air like I could just imagine it in
Japanese with the subtitles where he's
he's exclaiming of course I will and
99 of the time that would not work you
know and you I would see something like
a moment like that in an anime if you're
like well that wouldn't translate well
to the lot to like live action that
wouldn't translate well and then somehow
this show manages to pull off some [__]
like that where you're like that's great
that's cool you know like they I think
it says they earn those moments they
really do even even amid such a serious
moment because they did such a great job
of showing Luffy through the goofy sides
to give him a serious moment to then
watch that be
um this embellishment of all these other
qualities all it's like this is this
beautiful burrito of like seriousness
and childlike Wonder All in One and it's
just one of course I will moment that I
thought was great and the actress plays
on me I thought is uh
her performance has been very consistent
it's quite excellent here yeah
and I love that this show has let us
know everyone's motivation has let us
know because everyone's usually set up
with some type of mystery and then
sometimes a show will stretch that [__]
out until like season two or three if
we're talking just even live active
shirt and Anime it like goes on for a
much longer time right but in live
action they'll stretch that out for what
feels like [__] forever and then here
I love that we actually got it and we
now know everyone's backstory and we see
that this Suicide Squad of sorts uh some
kind of Suicide Squad yeah of how they
are a fan of how they can
they can be a family yeah because they
don't have
they don't have family anymore
and you know it's like Nami has family
and stuff but you could see how them
setting on all these and I like how they
all have like different conquests that
they're after these different Adventures
after and uh while I while I do like I I
enjoy our long uh I enjoy the design of
the fish people and stuff and I I enjoy
the commentary that they make and I like
how nuanced it is I really like how
nuanced it is yeah where he's not just a
guy who terrorizes and that there is at
the end of the day a lot of well racism
until I dealt his way or what would you
call fishism humanism yeah some type of
some discrimination xenophobia uh type
of thing Eric yeah yeah there's there at
the end of the day there's
um a lot of systematic injustices that
have been dealt his way that have formed
him has formed him to be the the rage
the wrathful man that he is and
at the end of the day still is like
still a villain yeah
I I like uh I like the layers a lot to
him and I can't quite pinpoint it yet
and I wonder if it's because the show
has introduced us to other villains who
I've just thought have been more
engaging and ultimately scary like when
there's someone like mihawk out there
yeah I'm not as scared of an AR long
because I'm like I feel like a Miha
could easily kill this guy
when when they're talking so you know
what it is actually I think it's it
might be because our log was in like one
episode
and then like for a little bit and then
he came into last episode and was like
more predominant
and mihawk was only one episode two
right but it's presence no I'm not uh no
I'm saying no I'm thinking of a
different point here is that why this
this thing about our long and
I guess they're kind of sitting like
he's like the main there's a lot of
villains yeah you know right now there's
there's a lot of villains and I could
and I think it's one of the joys of a of
a series is you can have ultimate
villains especially the anime where you
can have multiple villains and stuff and
uh I think that
I don't quite know what it is yet maybe
I'll maybe I'll wait on that thought I'm
gonna I'm gonna rest on that thought
before we get to the fine until we watch
the final episode because
I'm like is there too many villains yeah
uh because like mihawk seems like he's a
personal villain for Zorro for Zorro and
he's not really like a villain you know
and then you have the captain who's more
for like yeah he's hungry the Pirates in
general but he's more for Luffy and then
actually no now I think about it yeah
every every villain seems to have one
that's like okay but yes our long is
threatening to take over all of humanity
and to like you know rule at all but
he's mainly here to serve for Nami yeah
you know and then Usopp had the butler
that's been dealt with yeah you know
um
[Music]
so he didn't die though right no he
didn't no no he was he was uh rowing
away yeah yeah uh
yeah I think like with the way they've
been I guess the way this episode
treated our long I felt like our long
should have been in the show longer
or built him up longer yeah especially
when there's such a
diabolicalness to the the way it's all
coming across and such like a huge thing
like they're now gonna say like he's got
the map he's gonna set sail and take
over I'm like oh I feel like there
should have been maybe more of a build
up
to it yeah but I don't know like I
really don't know yet yeah I think I
said like I can't remember which episode
it was because we kind of like watched
these like in in pairs but it was
I think I said that like yeah that would
come the final finale would come down to
um our long and uh and GARP being like
the two
coming to head or like two people we'd
be facing in the finale episode and yeah
I don't think I don't necessarily think
GARP is super threatening but I think
that they serve our characters well as
far as like what they mean for them and
I think that mihawk was both cool and
serves for um for Zorro now
could he have been in the episodes more
I do agree you know maybe like build up
to this threat that he's supposed to
represent uh I do think that
they've you they've utilized him well in
the time that we've we've seen him and I
think he's the only one
so far that like I I get where he's
coming from but he has like that thing
that makes him corrupt you know like oh
like I understand why you feel the way
you do but like you're taking it like
too far like you took it like a a
direction that like kind of get where I
can't align with you you know like
like like a killmonger like a Magneto
you know and well I feel like the
dialogue provides that but I kind of
feel like the performance misses some of
that Nuance I think it's because of the
Prosthetics I was literally as I was
saying that I was wondering if that
might be it because because he at the
end of the day he does just play it like
Overlord at least the way it translates
he's just he's just a bet he's just
villainy and and when clearly there's
like through the dialogue I'm like well
it sounds like this guy's really there's
a lot of hurt and suffering this guy's
been dealt with dealing with you but he
it's kind of plays it feels like the
perf the performance feels a little bit
one note to me okay when the dialogue
and the context feels deeper than that
note yeah I think like the the this
place is Sinister you know yeah no I can
agree with that I think the the times
we've seen him like talk about the the
plights of being a fish person
and like the emotional weight of of that
has not been
um I don't know if congruence the right
word but to the same level as his level
of villainy or like yeah or the level of
Engagement we've seen him like there
there hasn't been anything
that has made him overtly threatening or
like oh like we got it we gotta take
this guy down in the in the same way
that we've um
it just seems like everywhere he goes
he's murdering left and right yeah yeah
we could we could use more you know and
I I do I can definitely agree with that
fact
um
yeah I look I will say that being said I
look forward to having Nami get her
revenge on this guy yeah yeah what he's
doing to the town for what he did to the
mother you know yeah and I don't think
it's a satisfying villain for our crew
but more so specifically for her and I
feel like all of the villains to an
extent have been like
I mean satisfying for individual Heroes
to take down except for usab doesn't
really you know suffer Luffy you know
get his rematch get his rematch too
you're right there there's a person
element for him there as well yeah
um we'll see I don't know like I'd
rather wait till the final episode for
actually casting a final judgment about
it fair okay
um
yeah I like the sister too she was a
good performer she was good
um alrighty well one more to go we'll
see how it goes alrighty excited for it
thank you guys for being here and we'll
see you for the finale bye
[Music]